we are going to be uh talking about a
number of aspects of a weekend
republican donor event that took place
at donald trump's florida club doral
looks like doral to me i don't know why
they say doral but if that's what they
say i'll say it it took place this
weekend we're going to talk
yes about what donald trump said but
really the relevance of trump now
is more now that he's out of office the
relevance is
what happens to the followers of trump
in the republican party because
they really are the future of the party
the followers will decide
whether it's trump or someone else at
the head of the party
in 2024 and they will decide whether
these trumpian republican officials get
reelected or removed in 2022
and so okay hearing what trump says fine
but hearing from his followers and from
republican donors
that's really the future of the party
and it's unfortunately as bad
as anybody could have imagined we're
going to look
at an interview with a woman that cnn
spoke to
in florida at this republican donor
event at which donald trump also spoke
over the weekend
i was looking at this like the zapruder
film i mean you you almost have to go
frame by frame
because there is so much ignorance and
delusion
and toxicity packed into a really small
amount of video
so let's just jump right into the first
clip
and i do believe that the election was
stolen
and i do believe that it was a peaceful
rally that day and that just because
people who are in the capital were
wearing trump shirts and trump hats
doesn't necessarily make them trump
supporters
anybody can get one of those shirts so
that is merely
18 seconds and it is filled
with ignorance that could take months to
overcome
and change people's minds about i do
believe the election was stolen she says
she's not a lone nut i mean she's a nut
but she's not a loan
nut because 60 percent of republicans
believe
exactly that 60 percent of republicans
believe that donald trump was
the rightful winner of the november 2020
election now
december january february march april
we're we're now five months out
60 of them still believe that okay that
is not a fringe view
there are you could have tens of
millions of conversations
just like this one with other trump
voters
she says the trump riots were mostly
peaceful
and not really trump supporters half of
republicans believe that
and the reporter tries to explain we
know that they were trump supporters
there is no doubt when
when we look at the court cases we find
you know years of pro-trump social media
activity
at some point you have to apply occam's
razor did they two years ago
three years ago five years ago knowing
on january 6 they were going to pretend
to be trumpists
start falsely seeding
sed false pro-trump stuff on their
social media or
if it walks like a duck and it sounds
like a duck it's simply a duck
and she doesn't care when she's
presented with that take a listen
but a lot of them have been shown to be
real trump supporters right through
indictments that they've been a long
long time support of trump
i don't know that to be true so this is
really a case of burden of proof
she believes without evidence that the
trumpists at the riots were fake trump
supporters
there's no evidence of that there is
evidence that
they are real trump supporters but she
hasn't seen it
so she dismisses it out of hand this is
a really big epistemological hurdle to
clear and we've talked about it before
um very very difficult and the most
effective way is
you build a rapport with this person and
over a period of months
you can maybe get them to change their
view that doesn't work when it's 75
million people that believe this stuff
it's just just a fact of of math quite
frankly
let's continue i think some people will
watch this who are not trump supporters
and they'll say here's a trump supporter
who's in denial about january 6 would it
not be better to
sort of have to say that to me because
i've had friends and family already
say that to me you know because they
disagree they think that
i'm crazy that i'm a conspiracy theorist
because the election was stolen
now that is fascinating she says forget
about
your audience saying i'm in denial my
family and friends has already been
telling me
that for months and yet it seems to only
further her belief that she is correct
this goes back to another principle
we've talked about
uh oftentimes when people are you know
kind of bashed over the head with facts
they don't change their mind they
further
attach or or align themselves to their
beliefs
when they are told by others that's
crazy
they don't say well maybe it is they
further
plant their feet in those beliefs and um
and and that uh it simply doesn't work
as we've talked about before let's look
at more of this
speaking of of your family calling you
conspiracy theorists
uh marjorie taylor green is going to be
speaking here this weekend
she's known as the by some as the q anon
congresswoman
i don't know what's so terrible but
terrible about q anon can you tell me
it's a basis conspiracy theory
well what's so you know what is so
terrible about conspiracy theories
anyway can you tell me i mean there's
there was
there were conspiracy theories behind
jfk's assassination i'm old enough to
remember
all the conspiracy theories that swirled
around his assassination
it's always it's always painted in such
a negative
way these conspiracy theories are are
cutting into the foundation of american
democracy
or helping inspire a violent
insurrection
no i don't believe that's the case in
what way can you explain
the lie the election was stolen oh well
see
that's where we part ways i don't
believe that it's a lie
i just love that you you actually see
if you're watching how she seems to be
back on the defensive for a moment there
but then she comes up with something
that in some republican circles is what
i call
faux enlightened f-a-u-x faux
enlightened
you can always these are crutches these
are
i wouldn't even call them
epistemological crutches because there's
no epistemology there
it's a rhetorical club a crutch where
you can always say
what's so bad about x anyway and that
makes you quote open to quote
ideas this is a really common thing that
people on the right
who know enough to know they know that
they don't really have
facts but they also have these
rhetorical crutches they can
put their weight on like turning
something back on on the other person
and then we get to what is now
one of the toughest problems that we're
dealing with which is disagreements
about what facts are now i
i've made this distinction before and
it's a really important one to
understand
we're not experiencing a disagreement
about what
the facts are we've had that forever
we're having a problem of lots of people
don't know
what type of statement is a statement of
fact and what type of statement is a
statement of opinion
much of right-wing media is built on the
fact that their audience doesn't know
the difference
a huge portion of this country
particularly on the american right
doesn't understand that not all
statements can be reduced to we have a
different
set of equally valid beliefs there are
knowable facts and there are opinions
but tons of americans don't know how to
categorize those types of statements
and there's really no easy recovery with
that and i know it's like a broken
record at this point
this goes back to education this goes
back to media literacy critical thinking
stuff you
you really have to start teaching around
age 11 or 12.
um i'm not saying that folks like this
woman
are in a literal sense too far gone but
if you've listened to the phone calls i
get on the show if you've seen the
interviews i do on the show
you know the level of work that would be
required
to change one mind for someone that is
so indoctrinated like this woman
imagine 75 million of these people
that's why i'm not optimistic that
these folks are the ones we can
necessarily bring back in bulk
it seems we need to to do a better job
of educating people never to fall for
this stuff in the first place but it's
going to be a very uphill battle
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called teddy stratford i love
these shirts and that's why i asked them
to be a sponsor of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because all of their shirts come
with a patented
zipper hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better and look better the carefully
designed shirt
is also cut in a way that improves the
look of your upper body physique it has
a really nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you
it also has a specially designed collar
that won't
fall down and lay flat which i love the
difference all around with these shirts
really is noticeable go check them out
at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout